For the most part, the victim is me, but I'm the
victim of my marriage because I couldn't contact her on the day of the birth, and
I was the
only one who was having entertainment that I didn't want to do.  My
feelings of insecurity were just
persistent, and no matter how I thought about it, I was the victim.I
thought that was the case anyway.It's
up to you to say bad things about your girlfriend, but you
even sent her a flower on your wedding anniversary.  Is that true?Have you ever expressed your
gratitude to her for taking care of the house every day, and
listened to her complaints and true feelings?I've
always treated her as the best woman in the world, but now I'm
interested in her.  The reason you didn't have it is because you're the one who
disappointed me. You don't even try to love, and you do
n't know how to give. She just wants you to take care of herself. She's not your
mom. Shut up, shut
up, shut up, you.  All you have to do is fall to the bottom with me. It
's fine. If you've fallen that far, just fall with me as you wish. Stingy
brother, what are you thinking? What do the zombie balls
react to and attack us by moving or smelling
?  Or it doesn't matter if it's your body temperature, that's the only way to erase it all.
[Applause] [
Music] It's a
lie. Don't come! Don't
come! [Music] But if you fall, you're not lucky, but if you lose your voice,
you're a zombie.  Even though I lived without it, it was still
perfect until I took a bath.